arie à leurs familles merci la parole
est à monsieur pierre lellouche merci
monsieur le premier ministre il ya 15
ans la chine accédez à l'organisation
mondiale du commerce et le protocole
d'adhésion prévoyait que le 11 décembre
c'est à dire dans exactement huit jours
la chine obtiendrait automatiquement le
statut d'économie de marché
l'accession à ce statut fait que toutes
les mesures de défense commerciale prise
par l'union européenne c'est-à-dire 56
des 73 mesures anti dumping qui concerne
la chine
toutes ces mesures tomberez n'importe
quel importateurs obtiendrait devant
n'importe quel tribunal français ou
étrangers
l'annulation des droits de douane contre
la chine or tout le problème c'est que
la chine n'est pas une économie de
marché elle reste lourdement
subventionné par l'état chinois et des
salaires très bas
deuxièmement elle représente la moitié
de notre déficit commercial 30 milliards
sur 60
troisièmement on pense que 350 mille
emplois en france seraient directement
impactés en cas de suppression des
mesures de défense commerciale alors
comme les états européens sont pas
d'accord entre eux et que personne n'ose
dire la vérité aux chinois l'afld à
savoir qu'ils n'ont pas le droit d'avoir
ce statut c'est la commission qui s'est
emparée du sujet s'est réveillée
brutalement le 9 novembre un mois avant
la date butoir
elle est en train de fabriquer une
directive qui doit prévoir une nouvelle
base juridique pour d'éventuelles
mesures de compensation contre les
importations chinoises à bas prix alors
la question que vous aurez vous posé
monsieur le premier ministre parce qu'on
vous a pas beaucoup entendus c'est une
litote sur ce sujet depuis longtemps
c'est les questions suivantes
premièrement qu'est ce que vous comptez
dire aux chinois
le onze des sens deuxièmement quelle est
votre évaluation de la future directive
européenne s'il y en a une
et troisièmement est ce que vous allez
la transmettre au parlement français
afin que nous puissions en évaluer les
conséquences sur l'emploi dans notre
pays
merci la parole et à monsieur mathias
fekl secrétaire d'état chargé du
commerce extérieur
de la promotion du tourisme et des
français de l'étranger merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député pierre
lellouche
nous avons souvent l'occasion d'échanger
sur la question de la mondialisation du
retour des règles après trente années de
dérégulation néolibérale et du retour de
la puissance publique en cette matière
est le premier ministre a récemment dans
une tribune rappelé la stratégie
française sur ce sujet qui concerne la
chine mais qui concerne aussi bien
d'autres parties du monde les états unis
et d'autres pays émergents sur la
question du statut des collines marché
vous avez raison de rappeler que la
chine a accédé à l' omc en 2001 et que
dans son protocole d'accession est prévu
un certain nombre de choses mais sont
prévues monsieur le professeur
nous avons travaillé depuis de longs
mois avec la commission européenne
pour parvenir à ce qui doit être
l'objectif c'est à dire les règles et la
possibilité pour nous de continuer à
prendre des mesures de protection et
d'anti dumping y compris après ce délai
des quinze ans où en est on au mois de
juillet dernier après avoir eu c'est
vrai des tentations contraire l'union
européenne est maintenant d'accord pour
dire que la chine et passe d'une
économie de marché et que donc elle
n'aura pas ce statut y compris à
l'échéance en décembre que vous avez
rappelé nous avons par ailleurs
travailler sur une nouvelle procédure de
calcul pour précisément pouvoir mettre
en oeuvre les instruments de réciprocité
nous sommes en train d'évaluer la
proposition de la commission européenne
qui a été formulée le 9 novembre et de
regarder tous les aspects légaux le
coeur des choses c'est la question de la
méthode de calcul qui doit prouver s'il
ya ou non de ping
parce que si la preuve est impossible à
porter évidemment nos entreprises seront
pénalisés mais nous sommes maintenant
sur la bonne voie pour que la france et
l'europe puisse continuer à faire de
l'anti dumping de protection de manière
efficace et réactive pour protéger nos
usines nos industries et notre emploi